[Música]
vemos ahora un vistazo al comportamiento
de los mercados en la jornada de hoy
para eso está con nosotros Juan Pablo
lucumí j.p bienvenido aquí a directo
América comenzamos hablando de las
grandes entidades financieras de la
región que lanzaron ayudas económicas
justamente para América Latina Buenas
noches Santiago Así es hablamos
puntualmente de la corporación andina de
fomento quien este jueves colocó 800
millones de dólares en bonos para
acompañar los planes de reactivación
económica y social de sus 21 países
miembros en la región la misión tiene un
vencimiento de tres años y un interés
anual del 5,2% y se suma a dos emisiones
globales anteriores en euros y en
dólares americanos pues norteamericanos
que Se realizaron este año por un plazo
de cinco años recordemos que los bonos
son básicamente una deuda en donde el
emisor del Bono compromete a devolverle
Pues el préstamo en una fecha acordada y
pues previamente con unos intereses
también
y ahora vamos a Estados Unidos hablar de
la huelga de trabajadores de la famosa
empresa Starbucks si en Santiago Pues a
la huelga le han puesto de nombre
levantamiento de la Copa roja traducido
pues al español y es que son más de 2000
trabajadores de más de 100 tiendas de
Starbucks los que salieron este jueves a
protestar botas represalias tomadas
contra los simpatizantes sindicales en
todo el país ahora con el nombre de la
Copa roja o el vaso rojo los empleados
repartieron un vaso reutilizable de ese
color a los clientes que compraban una
bebida esto como una iniciativa y que
pretende contrarrestar la operación de
marketing de la cadena de cafeterías más
grandes del país y cuáles son las
peticiones de los trabajadores Santiago
Pues los manifestantes exigen horarios
más regulares mejores salarios y que
Starbucks se siente a la mesa de
negociaciones con el movimiento
Starbucks workers United cuanto antes
Esto fue lo que ellos dijeron
en este momento no tenemos contrato la
gerencia no se sienta a la mesa con
nosotros y enfrentamos ya sabes una gran
escasez de personal no tenemos
suficiente equipo ni tiempos de
capacitación
no solo Starbucks sino cualquier
corporación cualquier empresa tiene que
hacer esa promesa a sus trabajadores a
ser tratados de manera justa Y darles ya
sabes la oportunidad de ser tratados
como parte de la empresa y no solo como
un número bueno se los contamos acá
muchísimos escándalos y lo dimos también
a conocer acaso se le evadimos datos de
inflación Durante los últimos meses y el
Reino Unido entonces llega un episodio
nuevo donde Presenta una evaluación
financiera Cuáles fueron las
conclusiones Santiago pues entre las
medidas del presupuesto de emergencia de
55 mil millones de libras esterlinas
figuran varios datos la reducción de la
base sobre la cual se comienza a apagar
el impuesto sobre la renta que está en
150.000 libras y quedará en poco más de
125 mil un impuesto temporal sobre las
ganancias extraordinarias para las
empresas generadoras de energía del 45%.
y desde enero del próximo año hasta
marzo de 2028 aumentará ese mismo
impuesto para las empresas de petróleo y
gas al 35% desde el 25 actual se
mantendrán beneficios Fiscales para la
generación de empleo y finalmente
reconoció que Reino Unido ya está en
recesión y que su pib retrocederá 1,4%
en 2023 recesión y con crisis energética
como lo tomaron los británicos Juan
Pablo dejemos que sean ellos mismos los
que nos cuenten Cómo recibieron la
medida
No creo que estemos haciendo lo
suficiente a pesar de los aumentos me
decepcionó un poco Solo hubo un aumento
del 10%, creo que probablemente
podríamos ir por un poco más pero es un
avance
como en todas las economías globales o
economías de altos ingresos como la del
Reino Unido era Inevitable que ocurriera
la recesión sin embargo vamos a ver
exactamente Cómo afecta eso a la ciudad
porque creo que Londres tiene la
habilidad y la capacidad de aguantar
Bueno ahora veamos los indicadores como
los falas principales bolsas alrededor
del mundo Juan Pablo Santiago pues las
bolsas en Estados Unidos cerraron a la
baja luego de más indicadores de la
reserva Federal de que podría necesitar
aumentar las tasas de interés mucho más
de lo que pues muchas personas esperan
para controlar la inflación las bolsas
europeas cerraron en terreno mixto solo
con el dax de Alemania con una leve
ganancia nuestra región también cerró
con un panorama mixto luego de que la
Bolsa Mexicana sea la única que haya
registrado una leve ganancia esto luego
de conocerse que el fondo monetario
internacional ratificó la línea de
crédito flexible al gobierno mexicano de
50.000 millones de dólares por más por
dos años más y la cifra del día para el
cierre 500 mil millones de dólares
entregará el empresario australiano
Andrew Forest para el lanzamiento de un
fondo de internacional de 25 mil
millones de dólares diseñado para ayudar
a Ucrania a reconstruirse después de la
invasión de Rusia lo que quiere decir
que dará el 2% de esa ayuda para el país
bajo ataque Muchas gracias Juan Pablo
por esta actualización de El Mundo de la
economía a continuación en directo
América ya viene el